[Música]
[Aplausos]
dime cómo viajas y te diré quién eres
uno de los viajes más espectaculares de
mi vida tenía como misión fotografiar a
un jaguar
tengo que confesarles que días antes de
salir estaba extremadamente nervioso
nunca había pasado más de unas pocas
horas en la selva después de vivir 23
años en la ciudad la verdad es que me
contacto con la naturaleza era mínimo
y además no conocía bien el sitio a
donde me llevaban
finalmente llegó el día
caminamos anduvimos por senderos
estuvimos en bicicleta conocimos el
hábitat y los lugares donde se mueve
este gran animal incluso vimos algunas
zonas arqueológicas y en sus frutos nos
mostraba la grandeza del jaguar
en la búsqueda del hardware encontramos
a especies de las cuales se alimentan
vimos lo que parecía hacer sus huellas y
estoy casi seguro que lo escuchamos muy
muy cerca
por supuesto no hay foto del jaguar
fotografiar en jaguar en su hábitat es
un privilegio que tienen muy pocos
sin embargo el hecho de no verlo no fue
motivo para no conocerlo para no
sentirlo cerca y sobre todo para darme
cuenta que nosotros como humanos y
algunas actividades económicas entre
ellas el turismo estamos destruyendo su
hábitat y lo estamos dejando al borde de
desaparecer
y ustedes se acuerdan de su último viaje
ya vi que sí porque incluso el semblante
les cambia
me gustaría que tratarán de responder en
lo individual y en lo privado tres
preguntas relacionadas sobre la última
vez que viajaron
la primera con cuántas personas
realmente interactuaron de cuántas
supieron aunque sea un poquito más que
su nombre que probablemente vieron en su
uniforme o leyeron en su mesita de noche
la segunda cuáles son los recursos
naturales y culturales más importantes
del sitio al que fueron y qué factores
los están poniendo en riesgo no importa
si no los vieron
y tercera simplemente que tan ordenada
dejaron su habitación al salir del hotel
si ustedes contestaron a una dos o tres
de estas preguntas muchas felicidades
ustedes son o somos de ese 20% de
personas y de turistas que viajan con
conciencia si solamente 1 de cada 5 de
los más de 1.300 millones de personas
que viajamos cada año a nivel
internacional y entonces qué pasa con el
otro 80% no les importa son
irresponsables o simplemente pensarán
que ya tengo suficientes preocupaciones
en mi vida diaria como para que además
cuando voy de vacaciones tenga que
pensar en algo más
si ustedes han escuchado la frase o peor
aún les ha pasado por la cabeza alguna
vez esa frase que dice como yo ya lo
pague
puedo comportarme como yo quiera un ojo
tenemos un problema
déjenme decirles que después de tantos
años estudiando el turismo y sus
impactos he descubierto una cosa muy
importante no hay un solo turista ni uno
solo que no sea corresponsable de la
mejora o del declive del lugar a donde
viaja
ojo es un dato muy importante y entonces
qué hacemos
quiero dejarles una frase que me
gustaría que se lleven guardada en la
mente pero sobre todo en el corazón para
la próxima vez que ustedes viajen
cuando viajamos lo que realmente hacemos
es visitar un sitio donde alguien más
vive
vamos a la casa de él o la taxista que
nos recoge en el aeropuerto vamos a la
casa del día de turistas que nos lleva
que nos lleva a una excursión pero
también viajamos al hábitat del tiburón
ballena de las aves y de otras muchas
especies e incluso vamos a hábitats que
son casa de otros organismos como por
ejemplo los humedales y su impresionante
producción de vida viajamos a un sitio
que es vital para alguien más
y si pensamos que el turismo es una
actividad de dos vías y no me refiero
solamente al ir a un sitio y regresar
sino me refiero a esta relación que
hacemos con los destinos y si viajamos a
sitios donde vive alguien más imagínense
al revés
tampoco les gustaría tener huéspedes
incómodos
no verdad entonces probablemente
necesitemos empezar a pensar de forma
más seria por qué y para qué viajamos
pero sobre todo cuál es el impacto que
nosotros generamos durante esos viajes
quiero contarles tres historias
seis días a la semana galicia que no se
ve ahí porque generalmente son de estas
personas que no vemos empuja su carro
por los pasillos del hotel donde trabaja
ella es responsable de dejar inmaculadas
cada una de las habitaciones que
nosotros usamos cuando vamos de
vacaciones 12 en una jornada de 8 horas
oa veces mucho más cada habitación es un
nuevo campo de batalla y su carro se
vuelve mucho más pesado a medida que se
llena de hadrones de sábanas de residuos
e incluso de toallas que probablemente
fueron usadas solamente un par de
minutos
su trabajo es complicado
al finalizar la jornada ella habrá
ganado 36 centavos de dólar por
habitación
que multiplicado por 12 da un total de 5
dólares en sus 8 horas
con eso y con las pocas propinas que
recibe mantiene a su familia y trata de
darles una mejor calidad de vida
su trabajo se vuelve todavía más
complicado cuando nosotros como turistas
somos descuidados e irresponsables y
hacemos para mejorar las condiciones de
trabajo de alicia se me ocurren muchas
cosas pero les propongo una muy sencilla
la próxima vez que viajen dejen la
habitación de su hotel lo más ordenada
posible
en medio de las áreas protegidas de
chiapas
existe un lugar y una gente que es
mágica jerónimo en conjunto con su
familia y con otras 2.500 familias hace
una labor extraordinaria
si ustedes se acuerdan de sus clases de
biología uno probablemente se acordarán
el servicio más importante que dan los
árboles nos ayudan a captar co2 dióxido
de carbono si ese gas que es uno de los
gases más contaminantes causantes del
efecto invernadero o cambio climático
etcétera etcétera y producen oxígeno ese
oxígeno que es vital para la vida
ellos literalmente abrazan a los árboles
como este guanacaste que ha crecido
medio metro de diámetro en los últimos
diez años con su trabajo no sólo
protegen a las especies no sólo nos
brindan oxígeno no sólo tienen una mejor
calidad de vida sino que nos permiten
mitigar los efectos y los impactos de
algunas actividades que nosotros como
humanos hacemos
alguna vez se han puesto a pensar en el
impacto que ustedes generan cuando toman
un avión
cuando se suben a su auto cuando viajan
en autobús cuando se hospedan en un
hotel o hacen alguna actividad
pues hoy se puede medir y a ese proceso
se le llama huella de carbono y se puede
medir tanto a nivel individual como a
nivel destino y a nivel por supuesto
actividad económica y les tengo una
noticia no tan buena el turismo a nivel
global es responsable del 8 por ciento
del total de emisiones de co2 o de
dióxido de carbono a la atmósfera
tal vez la cifra no les diga mucho pero
si les digo que es lo mismo o emiten la
misma cantidad que la india que es el
cuarto país más contaminante del planeta
probablemente lo podamos poner en
perspectiva
como hacemos entonces para disminuir
nuestro impacto yo les propongo que la
próxima vez que viajen midan su huella
de carbono y compensen sus emisiones en
proyectos con el de jerónimo así no
solamente vamos a lograr tener
comunidades más resilientes viajes más
responsables sino también pondremos
nuestro granito de arena en la lucha
contra el cambio climático
dos horas al sur de los dos destinos
turísticos más importantes de este país
se encuentra una comunidad privilegiada
por naturaleza desde antes que llegara
el turismo a la zona ellos conviven con
un sitio de espectacular belleza la
reserva de la biósfera más bonita del
mundo
sian ka'an
en maya significa lugar donde nace el
cielo
cuando román era un niño aprendió de sus
padres y de su comunidad a cuidar la
naturaleza
tiempo después román tuvo que salir de
su comunidad porque su comunidad llamada
muyil y que solamente tiene entre 200
250 habitantes no había oportunidad de
estudiar
román se convirtió en el primer
ingeniero en graduarse de toda su
comunidad
en el ínter su familia la gente de la
misma comunidad se dio cuenta que el
turismo podía ser una actividad
económica alternativa y que podía ser
una posibilidad para mejorar sus
condiciones de vida hoy román junto con
otros hombres y mujeres gestionan la
cooperativa de ecoturismo más importante
de méxico y me atrevería a decir del
mundo de la cual román es el gerente de
operaciones
cuando nosotros viajamos con ellos
nosotros no solo hacemos algo por
pasarla bien ese viaje no solo nos
cambia la vida a nosotros sino desde
hace años ese viaje le ha cambiado la
vida a la comunidad
como hacemos entonces para viajar de
forma más responsable yo les cuento que
desde aquella vez del jaguar
he tomado la decisión siempre de viajar
con una serie de objetos que me permiten
llenar mi maleta a veces
hasta sobrepeso llevo pero no me importa
y el día de hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes 5 cosas que llevo en todos mis
viajes y me gustaría invitarlos a
reflexionar y también a que ustedes las
lleven la próxima vez que viaje
curiosidad
para poder alejarnos de esos sitios
masivos de esos sitios que nos presentan
en las guías turísticas y descubrir los
rincones más bonitos de nuestros países
nuestras áreas protegidas nuestras zonas
arqueológicas nuestras reservas de la
biósfera por supuesto siempre viajando
de forma responsable tratando de no
pasarnos de la capacidad de carga y
haciendo ese pago que a veces decimos tú
si yo soy local porque tengo que pagar
ese pago que sirve para conservarlas
respeto por nuestras tradiciones y por
nuestras costumbres por los abuelos que
han mantenido estas tradiciones por
generaciones y que hoy gracias al
turismo las siguen manteniendo y se las
siguen pasando a los que vienen detrás
de ellos
congruencia con nuestras acciones y con
nuestros actos tratando siempre de
consumir de forma responsable
tal vez descubramos de esa forma que la
mejor langosta del mundo no está en el
restaurante de cinco tenedores sino en
la profundidad de nuestros mares y
pescar la cocinarla y comerla con
nuestros amigos los pescadores en su
casa es una experiencia que nos cambia
la vida
humildad para reconocer que el turismo
es mucho más que una cifra es mucho más
que un número que aporte a la economía
nacional es muchísimo más que una
posición en un ranking para compararnos
con otros estados o con otros países por
dios el turismo debe ser una experiencia
para todos los que formamos parte de
este viaje
y por supuesto compromiso con un viaje
de dos vías con un viaje de ida y vuelta
con un viaje que nos permita por
supuesto ser felices pero hacer felices
a los demás no dejemos en ningún momento
que esta felicidad se convierta en la
pesadilla de alguien que vive en un
destino turístico
yo vivo en un sitio maravilloso pero
también en uno de los destinos
turísticos más importantes del mundo
cancún
en los 14 años que he vivido aquí más o
menos han pasado por esta tierra 50
millones de turistas
siempre me he preguntado qué porcentaje
de ellos viaja de forma responsable
pero muchas veces también me pregunto
que sería diferente si todos ellos
hubieran viajado de esa manera
así que la próxima vez que vengan a mi
casa
o que viaje en la casa de alguien más
recuerden que su viaje puede cambiar
para bien o para mal la vida de miles de
personas por favor
hagámoslo para bien seamos turistas
responsables
[Aplausos]